our last and final speaker is David
Benjamin he's a founder and principal of
the architectural firm called the living
which is based in New York City and he's
going to be discussing while his talk is
called adaptation so who knows what that
means and I think it will help explain
what uh what he's trying to envision
with that so it's great to be here and
I'm just going to kind of jump right
into our approach and our projects at
the living which I think in in some ways
you know follow well in the sequence of
presentations it will share some
similarities to some of the stuff that
Lynne and her group by working on and
probably touch on some of the work of
others but I should say up front that
you know we do research and design
through real world applied projects and
so we we're often trying to imagine and
redesign things for tomorrow but with
kind of real world constraints today by
making full scale functioning prototypes
of our ideas today with all of the kind
of friction that it requires to make it
work in the real world and so our work
has as involved in the past few years a
kind of intersection of biology
computation and design and this will
probably be familiar after the talks
from the conference so far but we we
certainly think that biology of today is
very different than biology of a hundred
years ago and certainly biology before
that of course architects have been
fascinated by biology for many years but
only recently has it been possible to do
things like this this is from a lab that
we collaborate with using microfluidics
to grow cells in isolation instead of in
an organism using quantum dots to
visualize the neurons
firing in a tadpole a live tadpole and
doing things like seeing at all and then
studying stem cells as they send
molecular signals to each other and
determine whether to grow into heart
tissue bone tissue skin tissue etc we've
also been working with some biology labs
including the large Detrick lab at
Columbia University to take some of the
amazing properties of say natural
organic growth like the growth of growth
of these biofilms about about the size
of a quarter and apply some techniques
of computations such as machine learning
and computer vision to try to understand
what they're doing and encapsulate it in
a computer model and that's exciting for
me because once we can do that once we
can have a computer model even if it's a
rough computer model of what's happening
with natural biological growth then we
can potentially start using it as part
of a design ecosystem and I'm going to
kind of skip this slide to start with
three approaches that we have been
experimenting with in our studio that we
think are particularly relevant and
interesting and useful kind of in this
context in this context of using nature
using live organisms in some cases a
version of editing nature in order to
make kind of real applications so
they're going to be three approaches and
the first one is bio computation and by
that I mean using actual living
organisms as tiny computers to solve a
problem in a different context and often
at a different scale and this project
started with the real world commissioned
by the airplane manufacturer Airbus to
redesign kind of their process for
design itself for making airplanes but
starting of course with a kind of
inquiry in an incremental way with this
component you see here in red
called a partition and of course
everyone's seen this component many
times and in some ways it's one of the
most boring components of an airplane
but it actually is very challenging to
design from a structural engineering
point of view and so you can see here a
crash test with crash test dummies of
the certification process for the
partition that's flying today in Airbus
planes and just by kind of watching the
response of those crash test dummies to
the forces you get the sense that in
4/10 of a second this is the amount of
force that this panel has to withstand
and it's it's worth noting that it's not
only a lot of force that the panel has
to withstand but there are a lot of
geometric constraints that make this a
hard problem to solve in other words you
can only attach this panel to the
fuselage and four points to at the top
and two at the bottom there has to be
the fold down cabin a tendency which you
saw in the previous slide and that has
to be hanging off of the panel just on
one side so that's a very a symmetrical
load which could be a challenge the
panel can only be about one inch thick
and to top it off you have to be able to
remove that Center area the smaller
shape embedded there because if people
get injured these days in the seats the
seating area of an airplane you have to
be able to put the injured person on a
stretcher and bring them around the
corner out through the door that doesn't
work with the normal turning radius of
the walls like right next to each other
so you have to be able to remove a slot
from the wall I mean it sounds simple
but that's exactly where a structural
engineer would want to place some of the
heaviest structure so it's at this point
that we turned to a version of bio
computing and we used this fairly famous
example of slime mold growth and to me
one of the fascinating things about
slime mold growth is that it creates a
an adaptive Network that is both
efficient and redundant so slime mold is
starting in that center area as you can
see in the video it's growing out too
reach sources of food which are those
white dots and it's doing that in a way
that's efficient so it uses a small
amount of connective material parts of
itself its own body to connect the dots
but it's also redundant in that if you
remove one of the paths typically it can
route around the problem and although
it's an entirely different material and
system we thought this 2-dimensional
adaptive Network that's efficient and
redundant could be a good way to solve a
more or less two dimensional structural
problem so we created a kind of custom
algorithm loosely modeled on the slime
mold growth used a version of
evolutionary computing or a kind of
artificial version of evolution in the
computer to explore many design options
and ultimately arrive at something
that's very different than what standard
engineering approach would create part
of the power of this approach and of
using the computer is that you can
generate evaluate and evolve literally
thousands and tens of thousands of
design options they're shown in the
previous slide as their geometry but we
also have these very large data sets and
we can use some techniques of data
analysis to color code the designs by
their type of design almost like their
digital DNA that creates the kind of
designs you can sort them according to
your two goals so in this case we want
to be low on the x axis and on the y
axis near the origin point to minimize
the amount of weight of the object and
also minimize the displacement under
stress you can hone in on the
mathematically best set of designs
through again other kind of computer
techniques and ultimately this allows us
to use a variety of techniques starting
with what we call a kind of biological
algorithm
derived from slime mold but then
extending to some other types of
computation and engineering to create a
new version of designing lighter weight
airplane parts just like natural systems
we can apply this
multiple scales so without going into
too much detail I'll just note that we
start with a kind of problem description
on the left the shape that we have to
work with we create a network of these
thin gray lines in the middle but then
everything gray line can in itself be
made up of a bunch of tiny red lines so
we can reapply the optimization process
at a different scale so here's a
different view of that you see that we
create and first these just kind of
standard profile bars and then a kind of
micro lattice of tiny bars that make up
those bigger bars as I mentioned this is
a real-world project and we have worked
with our collaborators that are bused to
create now what is the largest metal 3d
printed airplane component which is
designed to be certified and fly in the
plane so we're trying to push some
limits of techniques in design but also
use all of the constraints of real-world
materials production and certification
you know here are some of the components
printed on the bed of a 3d printer and
here's the way that it will kind of
assemble with the very thin cover on the
front and ultimately the reason we're
we're doing this and the reason that
Airbus is kind of investing in this kind
of research is that they want to reduce
the weight of airplane parts that
translates to a reduction in the fuel
consumption which obviously saves money
but it also saves on carbon emissions
and that's a big concern for Airbus and
the whole aerospace industry right now
so compared to the existing partition on
the left our partition weighs about 50
percent less and it's just as strong
even a little bit stronger we have
created this in full-scale and it's
about to undergo the dramatic 16g crash
test in a couple of months
the second approach that I want to talk
about is biosensing so the first one bio
computing this one biosensing and this
one means using actual living organisms
we just heard some great versions of it
from Lin but in our case we're using
actual living organisms so far without
any gene editing or bioengineering but
we think it this technique could be
enhanced potentially by this kind of
engineering but using actual living
organisms in order to sense conditions
of their environment and respond
accordingly and the context for this
project is a public interface to water
quality so this is a photograph of an
early installation that we did of a
network of floating lights you can see
them in blue here right off of Manhattan
and you can see the Manhattan Bridge
there and Brooklyn Bridge in the
background the lights change color and
they give the public an interface to the
quality of the water a condition that's
normally invisible but that we think is
important to the life of the city so the
kind of physical basis of the project is
is these six foot long floating tubes
that have lights above water and sensors
below water we have used some of the
materials digital materials of the
so-called Internet of Things sensors and
small microcontrollers attached to LED
lights but recently we've added to the
mix actual living biosensors and by this
I mean live muscles and as you probably
know and as you can see here in this
video
muscles open and close their shells a
small amount as part of their natural
living conditions so you can see these
muscles kind of pulsing around a little
bit in this sped up video but what's
interesting to me is that it turns out
that the rate and the amount that
muscles open and close their shells is
an incredibly sensitive and
sophisticated detector of water
pollution and so if you
attach a $2 Hall effect sensor to one
half of a mussels shell and an
inexpensive magnet to the other half
then you can get a digital signal based
on this very complex biological function
and you can basically harness a mussel
to be a detector of water pollution that
in some ways is better than our kind of
most sophisticated single purpose
digital sensors so we can get a mussel
sensor for a couple dollars and it could
be better than a $10,000 dissolved
oxygen sensor so that's certainly an
interesting way to maybe save money and
design but what's more interesting to me
is that it kind of represents an example
of the possibility that we can combine
artificial intelligence with natural
intelligence in other words we can
combine the best the computer has to
offer the holy grail of AI with kind of
evolved intelligence that already exists
around us in the natural world and we
could think of using them each as part
of our design palette and potentially
hybridizing them and to me that as a
designer that opens up a whole new world
of possibilities you know much beyond
this project for ways that we could
approach design problems so back to this
installation here you see our floating
network of lights this was an early
prototype installation in the East River
in the context of other lights in the
city and here you see an example of a
kind of tipping point in the data so
this is the kind of interface we'll
offer to the public a kind of warm
reddish quality means that the water is
a little worse than it was a week ago
and a blue color means the reverse so
that was just a tipping point in the
data that we captured there and like
many of our projects we create kind of
quick prototypes to test ideas but this
particular prototype has grown into a
commission to do a larger scale
permanent installation and commissioned
by the city of New York and so this is
going to go into construction in the
late summer and my third and final
example and approach is biomanufacturing
and this one means using actual living
organisms as tiny factories to make the
building blocks of our buildings and
cities and objects and I'm going to show
now a video that we made as an entry
into a competition this is an
architectural competition for the Museum
of Modern Art and MoMA ps1 to design a
structure in their courtyard and this
was our vision inspired some of by some
of the examples of other people in this
room and some of the work that Lynne had
mentioned
and
yes
[Music]
so the idea of the project and the
reason I'm showing this video is this
kind of encapsulated the idea before we
started to encounter the constraints of
of actually making it real the idea of
the project was to use biomanufacturing
to use a living organism as a way to
make building blocks but more than that
it was also to see if we could create a
new approach to design and construction
with almost no waste almost no energy
required and almost no carbon emissions
and also an approach that would be
biodegradable and I think we'll will see
some of the similarities to the
materials and the drone that was
mentioned earlier but at this point our
idea was that maybe we could start with
something like the Earth's carbon cycle
this endless healthy loop of growth and
decay and regrowth and in contrast to
typical architectural approaches maybe
we could take low value raw materials we
could take waste rather than high value
raw material maybe we could spend a very
small amount of energy converting raw
material into building blocks instead of
typically spending a huge amount of
energy to do that maybe we could create
a normal typical building and then at
the end of the useful life of that
building would turn all of the matter
all of the physical stuff of that
building back to the carbon cycle
instead of putting our construction
waste in landfills for hundreds or
thousands of years as we typically do
how could we possibly do that it seems
kind of too good to be true especially
today but we used this which has already
been described a couple times in these
events and this is a microscope video of
the growth of mycelium so this is the
kind of filament like branching
structure of fungi as you know sometimes
as the root like structure of mushrooms
and it turns out that you can take this
a beautiful natural process and take
this material of mycelium and combine it
with agricultural waste not the
high-value part of Agriculture so not
something like the corn kernels but the
low value part of agriculture like the
chopped up corn stalks pack it into a
mold of almost any shape and in about
five days which you see here sped up it
will create a solid object it will grow
into a solid object and you can
potentially use those kind of solid
objects for a variety of things so this
is some video footage of eco ativ
startup in upstate New York that is
creating mycelium based materials for
use in packaging and we approached eco
ativ and collaborated with them to
create a new kind of architectural brick
out of this material since nobody had
made large-scale outdoor architecture
out of this material before we had to do
an incredible amount of testing here's
one of our bricks being crushed with a
hundred thousand pounds of force at a
testing lab at Columbia University we
also tested small assemblies of bricks
and we were doing this in part to learn
about this somewhat unknown material but
we were also doing it just based on the
practicality of getting the project done
in other words as we went to our
structural engineers at erä
our great collaborators on the on the
project one of the first things we
learned and it seems obvious of course
is that their proprietary structural
engineering software and for that matter
any structural engineering software in
the world doesn't have a drop-down menu
item for mushroom bricks when you're
specifying what the material is that
you're working with so we had to develop
that that material profile through
testing we also had some challenges in
creating a complex form with this
material in part because you can't cut
mycelium bricks on-site to make
specific shapes that will compromise
their durability so we created some
custom computer algorithms to figure out
how to solve basically a fitting problem
and a stacking problem we had to fit a
certain number of fixed size bricks onto
courses of different sizes as you go up
in the structure and we had to make sure
every brick overlapped with every with
two bricks below it with at least two
inches of overlap and that was a problem
that was easy to describe but difficult
to solve with this complex geometry when
we arrived on site to actually make this
for real we had done a lot of research a
lot of testing solved a lot of problems
but there were still some things that we
that we had to figure out in the field
and at this point we brought into our
research on materials and biology and
computation a kind of ecosystem of
intelligence and labor in other words we
had Columbia University graduate
students in architecture who know a lot
about computation and form and New York
City brick Masons who know a lot about
stacking objects and each of them had a
different experience and expertise but
none of them had made this kind of thing
in this way before so there was a really
interesting layer of problem-solving and
labor and intelligence in the project as
well so as I'm wrapping up here here's a
photo of the final structure in the
context of the typical glass and steel
buildings of Manhattan in the background
and they traditional clay brick
buildings of MoMA ps1 our project was in
many ways a kind of test at a medium
scale of this idea the structure was
about 41 feet tall and it used 10,000
bricks so this was a test like could we
really make something out in the world
like this would it work but in addition
to being a kind of technical
experiment to test the technical
performance of the material it was a
kind of creative experiment or an
atmospheric experiment as designers we
were curious what it would be like to
stand inside of this structure what
be the qualities of light and shadow and
pattern what would be the experience of
looking at material that was rough and
organic and slightly unfamiliar in the
foreground but having it disappear into
something that looked more knowable and
familiar in the background and finally
the ultimate test of these installations
at MoMA ps1 which happen every summer
now for the past 15 years is their
ability to host a party because every
Saturday 5,000 people come to this
courtyard to hear experimental
electronic music and this was the first
Saturday which was a kind of thrilling
but terrifying moment for us when this
unknown experiment and this new approach
to materials was literally climbed on
and touched and smelled and scratched by
the general public but in the end that
was totally fitting for us because this
idea of bringing a new experiment in
architecture and sometimes in biology
out into the world it's it's fitting for
us that it would happen in public in
culture in society not merely kind of in
our own studio and not merely a kind of
hidden corner of a construction lot the
way a lot of facade prototypes are
created in the world of architecture and
of course there was a kind of life of
its own that it took on in a kind of
public reaction and discussion through
new social media technologies part of
the idea of the project was to see if we
might be able to create a local
ecosystem of materials and energy and
flows and then finally what we were most
interested in the project was the
ability to deconstruct it at the end of
the summer
take all of those bricks crumble them
into smaller pieces and combine them
with yard waste and food scraps and
bacteria and worms and then in 60 days
true to the promise and idea of the
project all of that stuff all of that
physical matter that made this temporary
building was returned to soil which we
then gave to the city for tree planting
and even community gardens the community
gardens aspect shows that it's high
enough quality soil and non-toxic enough
to grow food out of and so I guess you
know to conclude the the big idea out of
the project that we're taking forward is
that maybe as architects and designers
we should think of designing to
disappear as much as we typically think
of designing to appear thank you
[Applause]
[Music]